hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
we're gonna be taking a look at Google
Drive which is brand new and Dropbox
which is kind of the old guy or the
household name now in case you're
unfamiliar with these two products or
basically think of it as is your flash
drive in the cloud that's how I
explained it to like old people
it's basically having a cloud backup
solution instead of a freaking gigantic
hard drive sitting on your desk almost
my entire existence is in the cloud I
backup videos to YouTube I backup photos
to Google Plus and Picasa I backup all
sorts of other things like documents to
Google Docs Google Docs is gone now it's
Google Drive let's take a look at both
of these services and how they stack up
so start with a look at the brand new
Google Drive smack app and it's
basically exactly like finder you find a
folder called Google Drive in it you can
navigate through folders and files here
just like you would on the regular
system and once you drag one in it'll
take a second to sync it'll upload and
yeah now it's backed up to the cloud you
don't need anything else just as a side
note there is also a Windows version of
this application but there is no Linux
version of this application why
hopefully developers are on that at
Google you know get on that and then
there's Google drive's web app basically
once you dragged it and synced all your
files through the desktop application
it'll show up in the web app in the same
folder that you put it in so you
navigate through folders the same way
you find your files you can view files
edit them share them collaborate all
this stuff happens in the web app which
is a huge feature of Google Drive
now Dropbox is nearly the same way it
also has a web app which allows you to
view all your different files and
folders and you can click through and
take a look at them if you want and
Dropbox also has a desktop application
for Mac OS 10 and windows which is
exactly the same way as Google drives
which is going through finder dragging
in files and syncing them for your Mac
people is also a menu bar icon for both
of these that indicates both the amount
of storage you have left and the ability
to change some preferences so both of
these have the ability to go up in that
menu bar and do some tinkering and stuff
that in Windows that's in the form of
the status bar down at the bottom right
hand corner but the biggest biggest
advantage of Google Drive on the
desktops is the web app search
functionality it's incredible basically
from Google Drive you can hit that
search button and search for the name of
an application search for the title
search for words that are inside of the
application words that are inside of a
presentation or a doc
all kinds of crazy stuff so if you have
a presentation and you have some words
in the presentation you can search for
it and you'll be able to find the
document that has those words in it
which is pretty freakin cool and on to
the mobile apps because that's pretty
important both of these applications
have an Android app and if you use
Dropbox for a while you're familiar with
it you know that it's been developed for
awhile so it has this neat tabbed
interface it performs really well it's
very very smooth and fluid on Android
4.0 it's really really saw it has a lot
of functionality you can download for
offline use
you can search you can view how much
storage you have left it's a very very
well-put-together functional application
and it's really really good Google Drive
on Android well it's a Google app for a
Google OS so you think it'd be really
solid right well it actually really is
it basically replaces Google Docs if you
had Google Docs on your device before
this features a lot of the same features
as the web app so you have live
collaboration you have the same search
functionality you have the same off save
for offline use so it's really really
nice app it functions with about the
same performance as a Google Docs app
which is decent it's not phenomenally
smooth or anything like that but it's
definitely a good app and I know that
Google is gonna be working on it cuz
this is version 1.0 and we know Google
never stays ad version 1.0 unless it's
Google Wave there's no iOS app for these
right now but coming soon it says on the
website so I'm hoping there's a
full-size iPad app and a an iPhone app
too I guess
so pricing this is also a huge
difference between Drive and Dropbox for
Dropbox you get 2 gigabytes for free and
then there's this button on the top
right send corner of the site that
allows you to get more free storage so
if you can refer other people who sign
up for Dropbox you'll get more free
storage added to your account
some people have tons of free storage on
Dropbox just from referring people with
Google Drive you start out with 5
gigabytes for free which would be a lot
of referrals in Dropbox and then you can
pay a very small amount of money for
other larger amounts of storage so I've
already upgraded my account for the 25
gigabytes which is 2 dollars and 50
cents per month and if you think about
it that's next to nothing for a ton of
storage and I have a lot of stuff in the
cloud including music pictures 8
megapixel photos from my camera it's
it's pretty solid so I'm glad I have
that extra space Dropbox upgrades are a
little
more expensive but obviously I'll have
both the links in the description so you
can check those out I just pointed
directly at my crotch so which is better
at this point it's really up to you and
your familiarity if you're familiar with
Dropbox you're going to want to try to
give Google Drive a chance you might not
want to immediately if you don't have
anything that's Google related in there
if you're a Google person or even an
Android person like me you're probably
definitely going to want to give Google
Drive a shot because it integrates so
well with other Google stuff like you
get that extra storage I was talking
about in Gmail and Picasa and you get
that awesome search functionality the
web app it's just all there already and
you get that shortcut from google.com
that says Drive it's just it's just so
convenient it just makes sense so I'm
giving dry of a shot I think I'm gonna
stick with Google Drive right now and
I'll keep you guys updated if that
changes let me know what you guys think
Drive or Dropbox because might switch
back to Dropbox give a thumbs up on this
video if you enjoyed it or if it was
entertaining either way thanks for
watching and thank you for subscribing
the support really means a lot and I'll
talk to you guys in the next video
thanks for watching guys
[Music]
you